today i'm going to talk about why i eat
four eggs a day and why you should as
well now you're probably wondering why i
consider myself an
egg spirt on eggs that's an
excellent question sorry i just had to
do that but it's primarily because i've
been eating so many eggs for so many
years that makes me an expert but
there's some really interesting
information about eggs and why you
should be eating more of them now the
first point i want to bring up is that
you can't really tell
how good an egg is by the color of the
egg yolk well at least recently because
they actually use
synthetic coloring now that they give
chickens
to
color the egg yolk on exactly what the
farmer wants and there's actually 15
different shades between yellow and
orange that you can pick
to determine what color your egg yolk is
going to be so unfortunately the egg
yolk nowadays doesn't really tell you
about the amount of nutrition in that
egg yolk they also use different
colorings in the meat itself so you can
turn like a pale white color
chicken meat into either yellow or a
beige color so apparently consumers
demand a certain color of their chicken
meat and their egg yolks but if you're
not using these color dyes and you look
at the actual color of the yolk
you can tell how much carotenoids
present in that egg
you can't tell the nutrition by the
color of the
shell okay because they come in
different colors that doesn't give you
too much data the nutrition of an egg
and a chicken is determined by how
they're raised and what they're fed and
unfortunately chickens nowadays just
have absolutely no flavor
like the chicken breast is bland they
actually have to flavor it i'm not
kidding next time you go to the store
look at the label for chicken breast and
you're going to notice it has natural
flavorings or even artificial flavorings
because you're trying to make this
tasteless bland piece of meat taste more
like chicken so unfortunately we have
grown chickens for size and we want
chickens that can grow fast because
chickens are sold by the weight now in
2015 the cost of a chicken was like
seven dollars okay now to me that's
actually pretty cheap because
i mean you have to grow the chicken you
have to take care of the chicken how are
you gonna make any profit at all if you
have to feed the chicken grain
and most of these chickens that are sold
conventionally are fed grain they're not
allowed to go out and eat bugs or worms
or any of that but in 1948 the cost of a
chicken was like three dollars now if we
compare that to the dollar now it would
be like buying a chicken for 30 dollars
and that is because the quality back
then is much greater than it is now now
before i get into the benefits of egg i
want to just quickly talk about
different terms that they use for eggs
so you have free range eggs right well
what does that actually mean well it
means that they're not in a cage they
are cage-free but it doesn't really mean
that they can go outside it just means
that they have access to the outside and
they don't define axis it could be some
small little hole in the barn
that they never find also the
verification process on free range
is
not followed up with an on-site
inspection so there's a lot of great
areas when you talk about free range and
then when we get to cage free it means
that they're just outside the cage which
is a step up and what about grade a
well that just means the shape of the
shell
is really nice and it has no cracks so
it's really just a marketing thing like
i'm sure you never go home and go wow
honey i have some grade a eggs they're
perfectly round and they have no cracks
then you have pasteurized eggs right
that does not mean
pasture raised okay raised on a pasture
outside it means that they're heated
which preserves them it makes them last
longer and then you get a vegetarian fed
right and yet this sounds very wonderful
vegetarian fed means you're feeding them
grains like soy and corn which are gmo
so i would recommend getting organic
pasta raised type eggs now what is
better than that well buy your eggs for
at a farmer's market
or
if you have a little bit of space
raise your own heads and get your eggs
that way and these are the type of eggs
that they produce
they produce a lot of eggs even in the
winter which they're normally not
supposed to produce we have like 16 eggs
every single day so we're still trying
to figure out what to do with all these
eggs but man there's such a big
difference between
these eggs that we're consuming and the
eggs that you buy at the store and i'm
doing a lot of experiments
on
growing animals and also growing
vegetables testing certain things out in
different soils
feeding animals different things to see
what produces
the healthiest animal and the healthiest
plant and i will be releasing this on a
new youtube channel but i will say that
growing your own chickens using organic
grains without corn and soy
is pretty darn expensive so we're
experimenting on different ways of
feeding animals that are not just
healthier but cheaper i mean check this
out right here this is
called fodder it's sprouted barley you
start with a certain amount of barley
seed
and then you let it sprout for seven
days and it increases in weight by seven
times this is like crack for your
chickens they love it so i will keep you
updated on that very very soon all right
so now let's talk about the benefits of
eggs and why you should be eating eggs
and just realize i don't eat my eggs for
breakfast i eat them at my lunch because
i fast of course it's a late lunch it's
probably around 2
2 30 maybe sometimes three o'clock so
number one
the protein in eggs is superior
and what i'm talking about is the
anabolic effect which means the ability
of that egg to help build
protein tissues in your body and the
percentage of how much that egg protein
is converted into body
protein
like your muscles your joints
and other proteins as well so if we
exclude breast milk okay protein is at
48
so 48 is turned into body tissue if
we're talking about meat or fish it's
only 32
and when we talk about soy protein
that's like 17
and as a side note egg white is only 17
when you add the yolk in there you get
more utilization which is interesting
and then whey protein is only 16
so what happens to the other part of
this protein well it's converted into
glucose and used as fuel now there's
another little thing about this i want
to mention and it's called insulin index
i talk about this in my book
but insulin index
is the scale of how a non-carbohydrate
food
influences insulin
and
whole eggs with the cholesterol
have a much lower
insulin
effect than egg whites
so the more that you take out fat and
have it as a pure protein as in whey
protein
the higher the insulin spike so eggs if
you compare that to anything else
is basically the best protein for you
all right next point is choline
choline
is really good for your brain
choline acts as a bile salt in your
liver it helps break down cholesterol so
it's a good antidote for gallstones it's
a good antidote for a fatty liver
and then we get to lecithin which is
also another antidote for cholesterol to
keep your cholesterol in check because
eggs come with cholesterol and a lot of
people are concerned about cholesterol
in fact there was a study out that said
that when you
eat eggs it increases your risk for
death from heart attacks by i think 17
but i did a whole video on that i will
put the link down below it's a
ridiculous study based on a
questionnaire
i wouldn't even call it a study because
this association was so weak and they
didn't talk about the million other
variables
that could have caused heart attacks and
without getting into it too much eggs
will increase your hdl uh more than the
ldl but that's for a different topic now
the other cool thing about eggs is that
they have a good amount of vitamin k2
which keeps the calcium out of the
arteries and keeps the calcium out of
the joints
and eggs also have vitamin d so vitamin
d and vitamin k2 work together and
there's not a lot of foods out there
that will give you vitamin d eggs also
have vitamin e good for the heart good
for the skin and eggs are loaded with
vitamin a the type that's extremely
bioavailable and it's called retinol so
part of these pigments in the vitamin a
complex are like yellow orange so the
deeper the color the more the vitamin a
you're going to get and eggs have
omega-3 fatty acids okay especially if
they're loud outside so they can eat
worms and insects eggs are loaded with b
vitamins b1 b2 b3
b6 b12 now i did mention that i feed my
chickens
a organic grain without the soy without
the corn
that grain is fermented for three days
to release a lot of the b vitamins and
other nutrients that are locked up in
that grain and not only is that more
nutritious you can feed them less
because it helps their digestion eggs
also have trace minerals and minerals
eggs also have carotenoids okay
that is a
nutrient-dense pigment that
gives that yolk the color but it also
has a lot of health benefits okay now
the two big carotenoids are number one
lutein which is yellow in color and
zeaxanthin
which is more orange both of these
pigments greatly improve the eye in fact
the greatest concentration of these
carotenoids are in the eye
so they support the lens the retina they
help prevent macular degeneration they
help reduce the blue light that you're
exposed to with all your computers and
cell phones etc but there's a lot of
other benefits too for your brain as
well now one question that has been
asked is how do you prepare an egg to
maximize the nutrition in the egg
because if you're going to heat it too
much you might destroy some of the
carotenoids and so poached or over easy
would be a great way to do that or if
you want scrambled what i'd recommend is
crack the egg inside the pan let the
whites turn a little white
and then turn the heat down and then mix
it up and scramble it after the white
part has turned a bit white this allows
you to preserve a lot of these nutrients
as compared to taking your egg in a bowl
and mixing it up and then putting it in
the frying pan so now that you know the
benefits of eggs if you're a small
person maybe you only have one or two
eggs if you're a larger person have
three or four and if you have any
considerations about the cholesterol and
eggs
you gotta check out this video right
here
you